[Music]
what is up everybody it's an iMac here
for anime uproar and welcome to another
installment or a weekly anime newscast
the links are in the description
recommendations go in the comment a
quick thank you to all of you who
commented on last week's video to let me
know that you enjoy these videos and
that you find them useful it really
means a lot to me and of course if you
do like these videos be sure to share
them with your friends especially if
your friends are too lazy to keep up
with anime news and they just want to
have everything in one spot every week
this past Sunday we had our very first
anime out / twitch stream and for this
stream we basically have a twitch party
where we play some jackbox party games
including quick flash - and it was so
much fun thank you to everyone who made
it out we are going to start streaming
regularly on Twitch over the summer
we're going to be playing party games
like the jack box games cards against
humanity' brawlhalla undertale and a
bunch of other anime games so be sure to
follow us on Twitch
I will leave the link in the description
it's always such a fun time it's a more
like intimate chill atmosphere on Twitch
and it's great so be sure to follow up
there I'm actually really happy that we
managed to figure out how to stream on
Twitch because it was our first time and
we are complete Twitch noobs but thank
you to Mackel not huge thanks to Mac for
helping us to figure it out he's been on
Twitch for a while he's a veteran he has
a dedicated community of fans on his
Twitch so I will leave his link in the
description as well be sure to check him
out I also want to give a big shout out
and thank you to our patrons
animail Pro is now only one page in a
way from having 10 patrons which is
crazy when we start our patreon we
weren't sure if anyone would actually
want to support us on patreon so it's
just such an honor it's so flattering
and it means a lot to us that you guys
are supporting us thank you so much also
this week we uploaded a brand new attack
on Titan video and in this video we
explain every single type of Titan and
the identity and abilities of every
known Titan shifter so if you're an
attack on Titan fan be sure to check it
out link in the description and just as
I was working on this week's video
WatchMojo uploaded a very interesting
video in my opinion in which they pit
code geass against Death Note now these
are two really iconic anime I personally
love them and they were actually my two
first mature anime
I ever watched MyGateway anime was Death
Note and the second anime that I watched
was Code Geass so like I said I thought
this video was really interesting in
this WatchMojo match of Death Note
actually came out on top of gordias
primarily because they felt that the
power of the Death Note is superior to
the power of Geass now I'm not sure I
actually I agree with this because
Lelouch with his power can control
anyone that he makes eye contact with
whereas Kira or light without Shinigami
eyes cannot do this so if like if a
Lucia's wearing a zero mask even if
light is right there this item he cannot
kill him
whereas zero could kill life or control
light so I don't know how I feel about
this guy's let me know what you think in
the comments do you think the Death Note
power is superior to Geass power and if
so why and there were some parts in this
video that I felt were just plain wrong
especially when they say that light is
actually a pretty good guy when he is
not trying to kill people and we know
that this is completely wrong because
light is a total sociopath who doesn't
care about anyone and doesn't care about
the consequences as long as he gets what
he wants and in fact this is what makes
the whole comparison between white and
Lelouch really interesting to me on the
one hand light has a god complex he's a
sociopath and he has almost no personal
attachments he will do whatever it takes
to his family to Misa in order to get
his way on the other hand Lelouch is
almost too attached to his sister to his
bestfriend Suzaku and he allows that
personal attachment to get in the way of
his overall goals and I thought that
this dichotomy between the two was
always an interesting aspect of
comparing Lydon Lelouch but let me know
what you think about this comparison in
the comments back in March we learned
that arica 7 will be getting a new
animated movie trilogy and just this
week we got the news that the first
movie in this trilogy called high
evolution 1 will premiere on September
16th in Japan now of course this is
great news for America 7 fans but if
you're a code geass fan that has been
waiting for over seven months for the
release date of the three recap films
that they said would be coming soon
you have to be a little bit salty just a
little bit salty I know I am anime North
2017 will be taking place this weekend
May 26 27th and 28th in Toronto Ontario
anime north is the biggest anime
convention in Canada and the second
biggest anime convention in North
America and this year both goes in and I
are going we're going to be there for
the whole weekend and we're actually
going to be meeting makkal not and
Briggs from all-day anime for the first
time and we hope we get to see some of
you guys there as well now while we're
at intermittent orth we won't have
access to all of our editing software so
the fancier videos will have to wait
until we come back however we will be
posting pics and some short videos on
our Twitter Instagram and Facebook
accounts so if you don't follow us on
social media yet all the links are in
the description be sure to follow us for
all the latest updates hour by hour and
day by day and another piece of anime
north news is that I am actually going
to be hosting a panel on anime and
philosophy at anime North this year this
panel will take place on Sunday at noon
in Burton one and two so if you're
around be sure to drop in and say hello
we will be discussing the philosophical
themes in some of our favorite anime and
while we're on the topic of anime North
this week makkal not uploaded a totally
legit Survival Guide for anime north and
this is definitely a must watch be sure
to check it out and it even it features
a dark plot twist in the shotgun Brin
saga scary stuff scary stuff be sure to
check it out and this week on rad cafe
on ethic showdown is gonna be happening
between two iconic shown an anime
Naruto and one piece and we are going to
determine once and for all which anime
is superior in this debate we're going
to have miss Hart and Lotus representing
the Naruto side and breaks from all the
anime and 2spooky representing the one
piece side be sure to check this out
do not miss it it's going to be taking
place on Thursday at 5 p.m. Eastern
Standard Time right here on the anime
Outdoor Channel
weak giggle uploaded a video about five
manga series that deserve more attention
and I thought this was a really good
video he went above and beyond in the
editing for this one so I highly
recommend checking it out this video
even features a clip of dream of mirrors
by Iron Maiden
near the end of the video and this is an
amazing song and I love Madon Madon
rules so that is another plus in my book
for this video also something apparently
happened in the Tokyo ghoul manga this
week 18 pages of something however I'm
not a Tokyo ghoul fan so I have no idea
what and my favorite a MV for this week
is an MV called day of the dead by baka
BR and V this video features a really
hype badass track combined with some
popular action anime and this guy does a
really good job be sure to check it out
this video had only 26 views and one
like when I first saw it but I'm sure
that we can change that right now and
that is it for this week guys as always
thank you so much for watching and if
you do enjoy these videos be sure to
LIKE and subscribe and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]